alright let's get started um Oh first
off we're supposed to be pushing
cardstock this week so let's push
cardstock this week also what is this
taper for what for recording Michael is
on vacation and he's asked me to record
all meetings and to type up the
transcripts ok uh Karen
any news from that law firm yeah the
deal closed yesterday it's a six month
commitment oh my god Dwight what are you
doing what you're not allowed to take
off your pants in the middle of the
office I'm not y-you know what just back
off okay that's making me uncomfortable
this is sexual harassment by the way oh
my god he's got a knife I do not have a
knife no let the record show that Dwight
K Schrute is now completely nude and is
holding a plastic knife to Stanley's
neck let the record show that Jim
Halpert is a liar
Dwight Roos not wearing a baby's bonnet
I am NOT here I just walked into I'd get
his autograph from I don't care do not
just walk in okay wait what is that on
your stomach is that a muppet babies dad
oh my god carry him right that is animal
from the Muppets you can't see my Stu I
am now chopping off Phyllis's head with
a chainsaw
you